o mesmo que quando eu que é o que eu
tenho mais fofo com a moody's pessoal de
quem falar que seja muito bem vindo está
mais um vídeo bom dia sp sol já acontece
em bonito é bonito e hoje que só a gente
fazer mais um perigoso que para quem não
conhece o uso que pra quem não viu o
vídeo passado vai ver no vídeo passado é
o nosso novo shopping aqui da casa só
tinha pesquisar alguns vídeos e vi que
muita gente brinca com isso indica os
gatinhos com laser tipos ficam looks vão
atrás do lazy e os nossos tais óculos o
que vamos ver como é que eu viajo
justamente essa brincadeira não faz mal
disse que o novo ponto laser a cara de
osório é claro pessoal claro que não vou
fazer isso aqui vai ser só uma
brincadeira mas vejam só que eu tenho
aqui falei não foi porque não gostou e
tenho uma caixa inteira
acreditamos na história o ste manter nem
se via um cão que organiza a presença
pessoal olha isso só acho que vai ficar
muito a tua quando vira estamos aqui
agora pelo quarto amistoso meu pulso que
já comentei em baixo o que acho que vai
acontecer acho que o que vai trazer
leiza acho que vai ignorar o argumento
já em baixa o que vai acontecer só
selecionamos aqui no canal já se
inscreveu mexer lá e isso ajuda muito o
canal só eu vou estar mais vídeos também
é importante e ajuda muito obrigado aqui
para quem está curioso aqui com as
novidades do quarto vejam só que já
estão é já estou aqui finalmente na
playstation 4 após divulgar ontem e hoje
tivemos aqui da fifa para ele só uma
coisa muito louca que eu comprei pela
luiz foi estancada pra vocês ganharam os
novos comandos assim e nunca esquecendo
sem bateria e eu pensei que não vinha há
sim uma coisa muito boa né mas ao final
acabou por voltar e isso funciona mesmo
fica muito bonita tem um enredo sul
meu incrível sul agora prestem atenção
uma coisa muito importante que chegou
pelo correio hoje mas não só
[Música]
só o single é hora e olha que tem mar
vamos fazer história ela quer tomar vão
vasculhar de 6 março nos cinemas
eu vou gostar do governo o filme também
inclusive vou postar uma foto não está a
surgir gritos portanto passaram mal e um
chute forte e eu gosto mas toda a gente
como eu sou a favor da criação eu vou
dar perguntei cuidado com esta mulher é
muito forte e eu também acho eu mesmo
pois é onde eu não sou quem me tem
ajudado pelo bom tempo no clube estou a
falar mal que receberiam se foi metade
os homens maus
robinho marquinhos 18 por favor do filme
an
meu deus pessoal a poderosa destruir ou
chegou vocês pensavam que era só homens
pela luta e dá um soco nem eu quero
muito este momento muito ansioso que
também vai mesmo que marcou também o
show vida curta brincar com o que vou
dizer vamos ver como ele vai reagir para
o que consegue mais pensou quando veio a
0 assim devem achar que é um inseto
super cap de uma formiga sei lá e mais
uma vez que só fizeram sentir em casa no
ponteiro laser os olhos do animal isso
sim faz mal eu caí
o palhaço bozo isso mesmo pois o que é
bom porque já fui muito mais a xinhua a
aep não tem nojo desse negócio é movido
a sonhos e não gosto nada em cima não
sei e não ter que responder só não gosta
de ver nos vídeos abaixo de 2 a 0 não é
assim então isso vai fazer com que vocês
acham que devem sentir vai fazer
temos uns na ponta nós
acho que a gente não quer só preciso
descansar contou fora já aguardava a
volta
eu não tenho vizinhos a 60 70 e isso dá
a patinha tanto mãe muito bom
eu só vou deitar agora que eu já esqueci
do país onde eu vou aproveitar o
facebook que está com câncer ele o time
que nem é sequer resumir meu querido
mini ópera mombuca que fosse buscar
essas bolas o que julgue na uneal essa
volta e meia na auto pode engasgar com
essa bolinha isso não é brinquedo pra
mim isto é um brinquedo pra mim é só
você fica mais aliviado porque eu
consegue roer a corda e consegue aliviar
os dentes
acho que esse incremento de 11 mortes o
que é sempre muito bom
em causa está a coleção boneco gastar e
lesou bateria é mesmo na gasolina é o
bateria que ataca ficará muito não tem
entrada de do iphone tinha entrado
fornece ontem a cantora já tá
ana que já estou sequer fui num quando a
l'express em nova iguaçu - mel
deixa eu fazer meu é só escolher antes
na outra cor 2 à noite acordou e freud
escreveu estou vendo os lances agora não
mas algumas coisas na nova linha já tem
mais só não fomos à casa dela para aí
alguém olha olha olha
o causo que não caiu sim desculpa do
animal
o dunga está fazendo uso que tropeçava
nas desculpas o que não foi por mal
ai ai ai ai que eu gosto de fitness na
barriga e ai ai eu quero uma mulher use
o que quer é uma mulher que eu quero é o
amor e isso é um fiel nunca penso que
isso que não não sou tão comum tec
aqui nós somos negra ou e negros
a cada semana os mais magros
não sou eu não é só em outra coisa que
chegou em casa de manhã
vejam só olha aí tem o capacete nível 3
do bid e e frigideira olha aí acho que é
fazer o povo de ir pra quem não sabe
antes oficiais em torno de um mesmo
álbum já está muito difícil não é uma
coisa pra mim ela é nossa já se
comentava uma janela tradicional
já agora aproveitem
e tem chique mas também da diplomacia de
lado a visão é tão xixi aqui ó longe e
vai constar junto pode atacá la
eu fui tocar no mínimo possível é a
sociedade pode ser um sonho ter sido
pior se a sua história o mal
hoje ele é muito novo e não conseguiu
chutar a bola é dada baixa silva velho e
só 51 estado já sabem comenta e passei
lá no instagram que o banco está uma
foto do capitão marvel eu vou sortear
bilhetes pro cinema 16 mas por lá
comenta ninguém fique bem e aproxima se